the search for gabby potito's fiance
hits day 19. gabby petito's parents are
speaking together in public for the
first time sitting down with dr phil
plus a message to brian laundry who
remains at the center of a nationwide
manhunt i want to see him in a jail cell
for the rest of his life we're not going
to let gabby be forgotten
in part two of their interview today
with dr phil gabby's mom dad and step
parents focused on her fiance the sole
person of interest in her death last
month brian returned home alone from a
cross-country road trip with gabby then
went camping with his family before
disappearing i do believe they know a
lot more information
do you believe he's hiding somewhere why
do you believe that because he's a
coward anyone that lived in that house
there's a coward if you lie that is a
crime nancy grace with et today she is
also blaming brian's parents after they
are confronted by the fbi they admit
that brian laundry actually left one day
earlier that gives him another day's
head start by mommy and daddy so if they
have not misled law enforcement they may
escape criminal liability right now they
are saying
to the effect oh the fbi jogged our
memories now we remember the last time
we saw our son
it was the day before i find that very
hard to believe
now dog the bounty hunter is in on the
search and a lot of people poo poo dog
the bounty hunter but you know what
reportedly dwayne chapman has handed
over evidence that he found near desoto
park
it's very important if these can be
linked back to brian laundry that gives
us an idea in which direction ryan
laundry was headed
i've joined the hunts for brian laundry
but of course with no resolution it's
gotten the snl treatment do you know
where he is
cuz i can't find this dude anyway
[Music]